Oh, the weather outside is frightful
his praise and worship and you didn't even ask.
But we're glad you're here if you're oh thank
you. Thank you didn't even
ask for Plaza either.
We're here. We missed one week.
Everybody's asking me is he going to be able
to fit all of this in three weeks and I said with
no trouble whatsoever and he won't skip anything.
Just kind of get it all in there. If you're a guest with us, we
want to say welcome and there's a cue card there and
we would love for you to QR code to scan that
in and let us know that you're here. I also want to
do invite you in three weeks. We're going to start a second
session another four week session and
it's called a my role in the culture wars
and we're going to be looking at some very extreme topics
that the church doesn't always look
at very closely and we'll be looking the very
first week at the our issue and as it
pertains to the lgbtq agenda and in the next week, we'll
be looking at our our role in the race relations issue.
We'll also be looking at climate change and what else
there's another thing and it's all about the same
kind of temperature. But anyway be in
prayer about that. It's going to be interesting information. We have
a Biblical world view. We don't have to shy but
I'll shy away or not not enter into
the exchange, but we do need to know that
God has given us a new king and a new kingdom and
a new agenda and how to respond to all those cultural issues.
And so that's coming up in not
next Wednesday, but the Wednesday after that we'll start
with my role in the court culture wars. Well, let
me start with a word of prayer and then we'll get started right away with Dr. Emerson.
Let's pray.
Father thank you so much for the opportunity to
meet together. We thank you Father that giving us a
warm place and a safe place to meet. Thank you for your word
and how it is a one story about how
you redeemed the the sin
in our lives and made us someone
that you can you can count on For Your Glory and
I just pray Lord that we would we would see the things
that we've not seen and how you're how your
scriptures all tied together around that beautiful Redemptive theme.
Thank you for Dr. Emerson for bringing him here with us. And
and we thank you for Jesus. Most of all, it's in his name.
We pray. Amen. Let's welcome Dr. Matthew Emerson.
Well glad to be back with y'all. I was disappointed not
to be able to come last week and was glad that
the roads are at least clear for another few hours so I
could come this week. So we've got
a lot to cover. I thought that I would
have some makeup time. Maybe if I needed it with a
fourth week, but we're gonna have to fly.
So last week we covered or two
weeks ago. We covered the first three chapters of the Old Testament.
Tonight we're going to cover the entire.
Old Testament from Genesis 4
to Malachi for so
as my friend Willie used to say in preaching class buckle up
because here we go.
Just really quick to review. We did
talk two weeks ago about the fact that in Genesis 1
God into God made
Adam and Eve to dwell with him forever
to glorify him and he gave them four tasks.
Do you remember what they were?
Dominion
obey
be fruitful multiply.
Care for God's place, right? So God made
Adam and Eve to be fruitful and multiply rule
over the Earth care for God's place and Obey
God's word.
Ultimately that was intended to fill the Earth
with other image bears.
of God
But instead of obeying Adam and Eve
sinned they failed to rule well by letting the
serpent into the garden and by letting him talk they fail
to obey.
and therefore
Sin, entered the world and affected the other
two tasks. They were going to have a hard time being fruitful and
multiplying.
God told Eve it's going to hurt for you to have babies. You're not
going to want to make babies and then it's gonna send effects
atom's ability to care for creation thorns
and thistles you'll bring forth from the Earth all it
is of your life.
So Sinners the world affects those four tasks, ultimately Adam
and Eve are cast out of the garden. So that sin doesn't just
affect Adam and Eve's tasks. It affects their ability to
relate to God to one another to
the world around them.
sin affects everything
So we ended two weeks ago by saying that God promised
in Genesis 3:15.
That he would send the seed of woman.
To restore what Adam lost to
reverse the curse of Adam and that's where we
left it and what I want you to what I want
you to remember as we begin our journey through the rest the Old
Testament is that the Old Testament is fundamentally.
a search for the seed
We are looking for the seed of woman.
The seed that will come and reverse the curse of
Adam the seed that will come and restore what Adam lost.
So we're not going to
be able to do what we did two weeks ago and walk sort
of verse by verse.
Three three chapters. I'm going to try to stop and pause
where I can but we're not going to
necessarily flip to every place that I'm going to mention. Okay.
So if you have questions tonight is
not the night to stop me to ask. I'm gonna try to bolt
to my car around 7:15 so I can make it home before the roads ice
again in Shawnee because there's another band of ice coming to
where I live. It might not hit edmon, but it's gonna hit Shawnee so
I'm gonna try to skate at all. But if you have questions keep them in mind and
I'll be happy to try to answer questions. You can
contact me in the middle of the week or next week when
I come. I'll try to answer those questions for you while I'm
here one last thing before we jump in last week.
I didn't mention OBU. I don't think at all. So this week,
I just decked it all out and and bison Green
I even have the OBU socks on. So if you want to
pair of those let me know. I'll try to hook you up. Okay, so we're looking
for the seed of woman.
and in Genesis 4
You know, I mean you get to think about this as you're reading
the Old Testament Genesis 3.
We're waiting on this seat of woman Genesis 4 Eve has
a kid.
Now look as as you're reading right you have
all this left and you know the story okay, but
just think about this if you're Adam and Eve.
Don't even just think about if you're Moses, Adam and Eve have a kid. What do you
think Eve's thinking?
Oh man, maybe it's this kid.
Maybe this kid is going to restore.
what me and
Dumbo over here lost in the garden.
And instead what happens?
Cain kills his brother Abel
things deteriorate very quickly
towards the end of Genesis 4
you have more children
that are mentioned and then Genesis 5.
What happens in well, actually indigenesis 4
not only does Cain kill his brother but lamech.
another descendant of Adam
kills a young boy
He just kind of gets mad and kills him.
He need to feel the depth of
depravity that exists already.
because we tend to think like
man, all Eve did was
eat a piece of fruit
But notice how quickly things deteriorate sin
is destructive sin is
pervasive sin has Cosmic effects
sin has personal and relational
effects already in the very next chapter.
You've got brother killing brother and then an older
man killing a young boy.
now that
I'm gonna I told you I wasn't gonna go slow but I'm
gonna go slow. So just think about this for
a second.
We're waiting on this seed of woman.
Eve's going hey, I just had two boys. I mean like
toss a coin god pick one of them. That's the reverse the curse guy,
right?
wrong
in fact if you look at
Genesis 4
verse 7
This is after Cain.
Has already become angry.
The Lord warns Cain and Genesis
4 verse 6. Why are you angry? And why is your face falling verse
7 if you do well, will you not be accepted? And
if you do not do well sin is crouching at the door.
Its desire is for you.
But you must rule over it. That's an
echo.
Both of what Adam and Eve
should have done they should have ruled over the serpent.
and also the effects
Of not ruling. Well, it's desire would be over. You
just like God said to Eve your desire your antagonism.
Your anger you're wanting to rule to
domineer will be over your husband sin wants to
dominate Cain.
But instead he should rule over it.
Like his parents should have ruled over the serpent. But what
does Cain do instead?
He kills his brother.
things deteriorate rapidly
This guy ain't the seed.
Dead Abel over there ain't the seed.
By the time you get to the end of the chapter.
A number of Generations on lamech isn't
the seed either he kills a young boy doesn't just kill his old his brother
who's around the same age.
He kills a young boy.
Things have already gotten crazy.
And then we get to Genesis 4:25.
Adam knew his wife again and she bore a son and called
his name Seth.
For she said God has appointed for me another Offspring
seed that's that word seed again.
God has appointed me another Offspring seed
instead of Abel.
For Cain killed him. You can hear the Hope in E's voice
and Adam's voice. I'm going to name this
kid Seth.
because
God is appointed.
another Offspring another seed
and then we get to Seth also a son was born
and he was called enosh.
And look at this at that time people began to call upon the
name of the Lord.
There's Hope here
the line of the seed prevails
people are turning to God maybe enosh.
Or Seth his dad is the seed.
And then we get this.
chapter
that is full of genealogies.
And here's where everybody if they're going through the Bible chapter by
chapter just stops and says
like you make it to January 5th, and you're like
God I can't do it anymore. Look at these genealogies.
Maybe you Prevail and you make it to my birthday January
10th, but then you're like, oh man, this is worse in January
5th. I can't do anymore.
Genealogies are really important.
The First Gospel in the New Testament starts off
with what?
a genealogy
genealogies are important because they are acknowledgments and
records of God's Providence over
history.
To say that even as we and this is really important throughout
Genesis. Even as we forget who God is
God doesn't forget us in our promises and his
promises that he's made to us so he doesn't forget right here.
Notice how many years this is I'm not going to count them all up, but it's hundreds
of thousands of years.
That pass hundreds or thousands of years that passed if
you get from Genesis 5 verse 1 all the way down to
verse.
32 notice that
he repeats Moses repeats Genesis 2
verse 4 basically here. This is the book
of the generation of Adam in Genesis 2 verse
4 and 5. This is the book of the generation of the
heavens and the Earth.
So he's trying to get you to pay attention.
Pay attention to this genealogy pay attention to
the Legacy.
That's happening when God created man. He
made him in the likeness of God male and female. He
created them and he blessed them and named the man when they were created.
He's repeating himself trying to get you to
pay attention. Don't skip over the genealogies read
through them. Look at God's Providence. Thank God for his Providence
over the course of a hundred 900,000 2000
years. However long it takes to get from Genesis 5:1
to Genesis 5:32 that God is
providential.
Over the course of history in making sure that
he fulfills his promises.
Cain already forgot God
five seconds
into his adult life
Adam and Eve forgot God five seconds into their
time in the garden.
Lamech forgets God and kills a young
boy, but God doesn't forget his promises to us.
contrast Abel's name
You know Abel's name means.
anybody
means breath
It's the same word that the writer of Ecclesiastes uses when he
says all is Vanity or all is vapor.
It's here and then it's gone.
That's what Abel's name means.
we
Both because we are finite we're not God and because we're falling
we're sinful.
We don't last.
We don't remember God's.
Instructions to us. We don't remember God's promises to
us, but God remembers his promises to us.
And keeps them.
So we read through these this genealogy number of
generations. And then finally we get to verse 32.
After Noah was 500 years old Noah father Shem ham and
japheth.
and then
so
we're going. All right, like God's tracking the line of the seed here.
Maybe this is gonna be it.
This is what you need to keep paying attention to as you read through the Old Testament.
Maybe this guy's the seed.
Maybe This Is It
But look what happens when man began to multiply on the
face of the land chapter 6 verse 1 and daughters were
born to them the sons of God saw that the daughters of
man were attractive.
And they took as their wives and they chose.
Then the Lord said my spirit shall not abide in man
forever for he is flesh his days shall be 120 years.
The Nephilim were on the earth in those days and also afterward when the
sons of God came into the daughters of man and they bore children
to them. These are the Mighty Men Who were of old the men
of renown?
Verse 5 and this is the key here. The Lord saw that
the wickedness of man was great in the Earth.
And that every intention of the thoughts of his heart was
only evil continually.
In the Lord was sorry that he had made man on the earth and it grieved
him to his heart. So the Lord said I will blot out man. Who am
I have created from the face of the land?
Listen to this language. I will blot out man. Whom I
have created from the face of the land man and
animals and creeping things and birds of
the heavens for I'm sorry that I have made them noticed. That's
a backwards order from Genesis 1
man
animals creeping things Birds
God is going to uncreate.
What he has created?
Why?
because
Verse 6 or verse 5 every intention
of the thoughts of his heart was only evil continually.
This is the back and forth of Genesis.
We're waiting on the seed who's going
to reverse the curse of Adam restore what Adam lost but everybody
is terrible.
At every step of the way.
Adam fails
Cain fails lamech fails
Hey, here's Noah. Let's see how he does.
Now I'm not gonna read this whole thing. I assume that you are familiar
relatively familiar with the story of the flood.
God tells Noah to build a boat.
Sends a flood rains for 40 days and
40 nights Noah and his three sons and their wives
are the only human beings on the boat. They
get all the other animals two by two on the ark God is
rescuing.
a remnant
from sinful Humanity
God sends this boat to rescue a Remnant
from sinful Humanity.
And notice what he says to Noah.
in verse 17
For behold, I will bring a flood of waters upon the
Earth To Destroy All Flesh.
In which is the Breath of Life under Heaven everything that is on
the Earth shall die.
But I will establish my Covenant with you and you
shall come into the ark you your sons and your wife and your son's
wives with you and of every living thing of All Flesh you
shall bring two of every sort into the ark to keep
them alive with you pay attention to the language. They shall be male and
female of the birds according to their kinds and
of the animals according to their kinds and of every creeping thing on
the ground according to its kind of every sort shall come
in to keep them alive also take with you every sort of
food that has eaten and store it up it shall service food for
you. And for them that is
the same language as Creation in Genesis
God is going to rescue Noah and
his family to create a new creation.
He's going to cleanse the world of sin, and he's
going to start afresh by redeeming a
remnant.
I mean, I I've got to move quicker than this you guys are killing
me with how slow you're making me go. No, it's my fault.
I mean if you if you were to read through the through chapter
7 you would see things like male and female over
and over again and verses 2 and 3 you would see things
like in them was the Breath of Life in verse
15. The 40 days is a really
important number for the rest of the Old Testament.
In any case in chapter 8 God remembered Noah and
all the beasts and all the livestock that were with him in the ark and God made
a wind notices. God made a wind a ruach a
spirit.
Yes, Siri, I don't
know if you guys heard that or not. But Siri thought I was talking to her. God made a wind
blow over the earth and the waters.
subsided
now remember what happened in Genesis
verse 2
the Earth was without form and void.
In the spirit hovered over the waters.
Well now the spirit and I think this is appropriate.
To say God made his own Spirit blow over the Earth in the waters subsided.
the Holy Spirit
Parts the waters
just like he does in Genesis 1 to separate
the water from the dry land.
Fountains of the deep and the windows of the heavens were closed the rain from the heavens was
restrained the waters were seated from the earth continually at the
end of 150 days. The waters had abated in the seventh month
on the 17th day of the month the art came to rest in the Mountains of Ararat.
Etc. Etc. Noah sends out Birds
Etc, etc. And then finally in verse 15 of chapter
8 God says to know it go out from the ark.
And verse 17 bring with you. Every living thing that is with you of All
Flesh birds and animals and every creeping thing that Creeps in the
Earth. Again. That's Genesis 1 straight out of it. And then look what he says that they
may swarm on the Earth.
And be fruitful and multiply.
On the earth this is this looks like new creation
and you're going I mean in your head you're going. All right.
Man Cain, he fell really fast.
Sorry Kane you're out.
Lamech not great. You're out. All these other dudes in
Genesis 5 dead. You're out Noah, though.
Man, Noah, no actually obeyed Noah built
the art God put all these people in an art maybe no
is the seed.
Then you start hearing this Genesis 1 and 2 language again
about being fruitful and multiplying.
Verse 20 Noah built an altar of to the Lord took some
very clean animal and some very clean bird and offered burnt offerings Noah's
worshiping God.
When the Lord smelled the pleasing Aroma the Lord said in his
heart, I will never again curse the ground because of man for the intention of man's
heart is evil from his youth.
Neither will I ever strike down every living creature as I've done while the Earth
remains seedtime and harvest cold and heat summer and winter day
and night shall not cease.
Now listen to this in chapter 9 verse 1 God blessed Noah and
his sons and said to them be fruitful and multiply and
fill the Earth.
That's a direct quote of Genesis, 1:28 and
26.
That's not quite the same though.
The fear of you and the dread of you shall be upon every beast of the
earth and upon every bird of the heavens upon everything that creeps
on the ground and the fish of the sea into your hands. They are delivered.
Every moving thing that lives shall be food for you.
And as I gave you the green plants I gave you everything so this is not quite the same. Something's still
not quite right.
But you shall not eat flesh with its life. That is it's blood. No, I'm not saying you
can't have steak in heaven because I'm gonna need a steak, but I'm just in in
Genesis 1 he only gives them green plants to eat.
And he doesn't say that Noah Noah will
strike fear in the animals. He says love dominion
over them doesn't say the fear him here. It's a
little bit different.
They're going to fear Noah. They're gonna be killed by Noah. It's
not quite the same.
Even though it sounds the same.
Verse 5 and for your life blood I will require Reckoning from every
Beast. I'll require it and from man from his fellow man. I will
require a reckoning for the life of man. Whoever sheds the
blood of Man by man. Shall his blood be shed for God made man in
his own image and you
be fruitful and multiplied team on
the earth and multiply in it. So it sounds
like
New Creation
But there are some hints.
That it's we're not quite there yet.
God is telling Noah to be fruitful multiply. He's put him on
dry land after partying The Waters at all. Sounds like Genesis
1 and 2 hurray we're back.
But look what Noah does after God makes his Covenant. God says, hey, I'm
not gonna flood the Earth again. I'm gonna put this sign a rainbow
in the air which is sort of like his bow.
Stretched towards heaven rather than towards Earth.
Is the image there?
I'm not going to destroy you again.
Here's my Covenant.
And what does Noah do?
Verse 18
The sons of Noah went forth from who went forth from the ark were Shem
ham and japheth. Ham was the father of Canaan.
These three were the sons of Noah and from these the people of the whole earth were
dispersed.
Noah began to be a man of the soil and he planted a
Vineyard.
He drank of the wine and became drunk and lay
uncovered uncovered in his tent he was naked not naked
and ham the father of Canaan saw the nakedness of his father and
told us to Brothers outside then sham and japheth
took a garment late once late on both their shoulders and walked backward
and covered the nakedness of their father their faces
were turned backward. They didn't see their father's nakedness. No awoke
friends wine and what his youngest son had done to him. He said
curse became in a servant of servant Shelly be to his brothers.
He also said blessed be the Lord the god of Shame and let Cain and
be a servant. May God enlarge japheth and let him join the tens of shim and let
Canaan be a servant.
After the flood Noah left 350 years all the days of
no were 950 years and he died.
Okay. So what we see in Genesis 6 through
9 is a an extended version.
of this pattern we've started to see
what we're waiting on is the seed of woman to restore
what Adam lost. We're waiting on a new
Adam.
We're waiting on someone to come and actually have dominion.
actually, obey
And then actually be fruitful multiply and care
for God's place and Noah.
Of everybody else so far.
Looks like he's the guy.
But just like Adam failed just like Cain
failed just like lamech failed.
Noah fails
Cain kills his brother lamette kills a young boy. Noah gets
drunk and naked.
Chapter 10 another genealogy things look pretty dire right
now in chapter 9 at the end.
Humanity's last best hope
Noah of the Ark
Failed, I mean think about it. God just destroyed everything.
Like no, no was it we're done.
It was Noah.
His three sons and their wives I'm not great at
math, but I think that's only eight people.
And the guy that looks like the new Adam is dunzo.
Nevertheless in spite of our sinfulness in
spite of our faithlessness God
remains faithful because Genesis 10 tracks a
genealogy.
once again
We're tracking this genealogy. It tracks shim. Cane
shim. Ham and japheth.
Kanan Sons become a ham Sons essentially
become the enemies of Israel.
sin has
generational consequences not that future. Generations
are responsible for their previous generation sins,
but that
sinful households produce
sin-filled children, and I'm not saying that you have
to be a perfect parent.
For your kids to be saved. That's not it at all.
The only thing that can save your kids is Jesus Christ
through the power of the Holy Spirit.
You can be the most perfect parent who's written all the parenting books in the world. And
that's still not going to save your kid.
But it is to say that turning away from the Lord.
And turning towards sin and idolatry.
without the grace of God
So all of us, that's everybody has generational
effects.
And that's what we see with hams line.
On the other hand what God is tracing through she and
jafest line, especially shims line is that
God is still gracious to us even
in spite of our faithlessness.
we don't deserve anything, right I mean
Know what doesn't deserve anything here.
Neither do his sons frankly.
They were sort of drug onto the boat.
And the only thing that Jim and japheth do well is that they
don't want to see their dad.
In a stupor with no clothes on well, okay, that's
not a really high bar for righteousness.
God demonstrates his faithfulness through tracking all of
these people throughout Genesis 10, then we get and we're like, all right, God you're
gonna bring somebody finally, right?
Genesis 11
Tower of Babel
The Descendants
of Noah's Three Sons settled together
build this Tower of Babel try to make their
way up to the heavens. Essentially. They're trying to be God
and God says Nope.
See you scatters them changes, everybody's
language. What was that? What were Adam and Eve supposed to do they're
supposed to be fruitful and multiply and fill the Earth instead.
These jabronis are building a tower in one place
trying to make their way up to be God.
The opposite of what they were supposed to do so God accomplishes his
purpose which is to fill the Earth.
But not in the way that Adam and Eve were supposed to feel the Earth Adam and
Eve were supposed to fill the Earth, you know obedience instead God
fills the Earth in spite of Humanity's Disobedience
Adam and Eve were supposed to worship God
in his place instead. These people are building
up a tower to God to be gods.
in the wrong place
So God scatters them this this is the
progression. I just I'm belaboring this in Genesis 4 through 11
because you need to see the progression.
This is a progression. We're going to see over and over again that
God
is faithful
and we see that especially through genealogies in Genesis.
in spite of our faithlessness
God calls Adam and Eve to
Rule, obey be fruitful multiply care
for creation, Adam and Eve fail.
He warns Cain don't let sin Master
you Cain fails lamech doesn't
even pay attention to God lamech fails.
God calls Noah you're gonna you and your
sons are going to be a Remnant Noah and his sons fail.
Humanity at the end of this
first section of Genesis Genesis 1 through 11
Is a total failure?
at this point
we've already seen in Genesis 6.
And really, you know, we've gone from murder.
To sexual sin and Genesis 6 with
the women and the sons of God whoever they
are. Maybe Angel maybe evil angels, maybe not.
Gone from murder to sexual sin.
to drunkenness
and perhaps for version there.
finally to
just pure blatant.
idolatry
Now we might reverse those.
Say idolatry is the least bad, but it's the worst.
And it's the root of all sin because you're putting yourself.
Or something else in place of the only God who
actually is God.
And at this point God could say I'm done.
But instead we get another genealogy.
Verse 10. These are the generations of Shem.
and at the end of the generations of Shem
we get in verse 27 of
chapter 11. These are the generations of terra, terra father Abram
nahorn and Iran father lot.
And so Abram enters the scene.
and
the story of Abram who becomes
Abraham
Is the story of what God is
going to do?
to redeem
the story of Abram who becomes Abraham is the story
of what God is going to do to redeem. Look at chapter 12 verse 1
Now the Lord said to Abram go from your country and your Kendra and
your father's house to land that I will show you and I will make of you
a great nation. I'll bless you and make your name great so that you will be a
blessing. I will bless those who bless you and him who dishonors you
all curse. And in you all the families of the Earth shall
be blessed.
And so they go and they move I'll come
back to that. Look at chapter 15. I'm just going to read you some of the promises that
God makes to Abram. So
look over in chapter 15.
After these things the word of the Lord came to Abram in a vision fear, not
Abram. I am your Shield your reward shall be very great. But Abram
said, oh Lord God, what will you give me for I
continue childless in the air of my house is Eleazar of Damascus
and Abrams said behold, you have given me no Offspring and
a member of my household will be my heir.
And behold the word of the Lord came to him this man shall
not be your Heir your very own son shall be your ear and he
brought him outside and said look toward heaven and Number the Stars if you
are able to number them then he said to him. So shall your Offspring
be and he believed the Lord and he counted
it to him as righteousness and he said
to him. I am the Lord who brought you out from Ur of the Chaldeans to give
you this land to possess, but he said oh Lord God, how am I to know
that I shall possess it?
Said to him bring me a heifer three years old a female goat three years old or
ran three years old a turtle dove and a young pigeon.
And he brought him all these cut them in half and Lady chaff over against
the other but he did not cut the birds in half.
And when Birds of Prey came down on the carcasses at Abram
drove them away as the sun was going down a deep sleep fell on
Abram and behold Dreadful and great Darkness fell upon him.
Then the Lord said to Abram no for certain that your Offspring
will be sojourners in a land that is not theirs and will be servants there
and they will be afflicted for 400 years, but I will bring judgment
on the nation that they serve and afterwards they shall come
out with great possessions as for yourself. You shall go to
your fathers and peace. You'll be buried in a good old age and
they shall come back here in the fourth generation for the iniquity of
the amorites is not yet complete.
And then the sun goes down a smoking fire pot
and the flaming torch passed between
the pieces and the Lord says to Abram to
your Offspring I give this land and then gives the boundaries.
Look at chapter 17.
verse 5
Well verse 4 behold my Covenant is with you and you should be the father of
a multitude of Nations no longer shall your name be
called Abram but your name Shall be Called Abraham for I've made
you the father of a multitude of Nations. I will make you exceedingly fruitful hear
that and I will make you into Nations and King
shall come from you and I will establish my Covenant between
me and you and your Offspring after you throughout their generations for
an Everlasting Covenant to be God to you and to
your Offspring hear that seed after you and I
will give to you and to your Offspring your seed after you
the land of your sojournings all the land of Canaan for
an everlasting possession and I will be their God
and God said to Abraham as for you. You shall keep my Covenant you
and your Offspring after you throughout their Generations.
This is my Covenant which you shall keep between me
and you and your Offspring after you every male among you shall be
circumcised.
So listen to what God promises Abram and later
named Abraham. I'm just going to call Abraham from
now on.
Listen to what God promises Abraham.
He says he's going to give him many descendants.
He says kings are going to come from your line.
he says I'm going to give you this land that's
Later described as flowing with milk and honey.
And I'm giving you a rule.
circumcision
Oh, and by the way, the the seed Offspring is
coming from your line.
many descendants
What's God promising to do?
he's promising to make sure that
his people are fruitful and multiply.
Kings are going to come from your line. What are Kings do?
They rule they have dominion.
I'm gonna give you a land that's flowing with milk and honey. So you
can care for it.
And I'm gonna give you a rule to obey.
Ultimately, your line is the line of the seed the
promise one is going to reverse the curse of Adam. Here's
the deal the Covenant that God makes labor and
the promises that God makes to Abraham our
promises of what God
will do which is to reverse the curse
of Adam to restore what Adam lost
the promises to Abraham are what God is going to do. He's
going to reverse the curse of Adam. It's
going to restore what Adam lost
That's what we're looking for. Listen. I I
talked about this two weeks ago, but it's really
important that you hear that sin doesn't just affect.
Adam and Eve's individual relationships with God it's certainly
does affect that.
But it also affects the very purpose for their
existence and the way God made the world it affects everything.
Thorn isn't thistles. You're gonna bring up from the ground cursed is
the ground because of you.
You're gonna hate your spouse. Your spouse is gonna hate
you. It's gonna hurt to make babies.
Your work is going to be futile. Everything that
God intended in creation is broken by
sin.
And here's what God is saying to Abraham.
I'm not just going to
help you fly away.
And not be here anymore and then blow everything
else up like Darth Vader does to Alder on
with the Death Star?
Instead what I'm going to do is I'm going
to redeem what Adam lost.
All of it.
My purpose is in creation are not going to be thwarted by
your sin and your disobedience.
Instead. I'm going to bring about I'm going to bring to pass what
I always intended.
Which is to fill the Earth with worshipers of Yahweh image
bearers.
Who will rule over God's Place care for it and obey his
word?
In Abraham, I'm going to do that through your line.
God's promises of Salvation are as big as
his purposes for creation.
God's promises of Salvation are as big as his
purposes for creation.
I don't have time for this but I'm gonna say it. Anyway, we look we
have this weird view of Salvation where it is
totally individualistic. It's just me and God, it's Josh
Turner.
I love Josh Turner got a great voice. That song
is terrible.
Me and go. Okay. No, look it's it's more
than you and God that God is saving
and restoring in sending his
son to die on the cross and rise from the dead. He is
saving you individually, but he's also restoring what Adam lost
all of it.
the whole thing the whole enchilada
when he promises to Abraham he's going to multiply his
descendants. His kings are
going to come from his line. He's gonna get a landfilling with milk and honey that he
gives him a rule to obey and that the sea is going to come from him.
That is a promise to restore all that atom lost.
This idea that we're going to you know float around
on clouds.
With angels wings and no bodies and no Earth,
but somehow we're all so playing a harp. That's not the vision of
salvation of the Bible gives.
The vision of redemption of the Bible gives is Cosmic.
That doesn't mean universal salvation for everybody.
People still have to repent and believe in the Lord. Jesus to be
saved.
But it does mean that God is doing something big
bigger than you and me individually.
In Salvation, he's restoring what Adam lost.
So we continue through the story of Abraham. I'm not
going to I don't have time to walk through most of
this. It would be great. If we did I thought about in the like 15
minutes ago just turning this into a study of Genesis for
four weeks, but I'll try to get a little bit further. So
here's the deal. If you have read this
story of Abraham, you know that the same pattern that we saw with Adam
and Cain and lamech and
Noah and the Tower of Babel that same
pattern exists with Abraham.
God calls Abraham from Ur of the Chaldeans Abraham
obeys comes down Builds an altar. Everything's
great. Very next verse. What does he do?
Goes down to Egypt tries to pass his wife off
as a sister. So the Pharaoh won't get mad at him.
God rescues him from that. What's the danger there?
It's not just a danger to their relationship. It's
a danger to the line of the seed.
Because a pharaoh goes in and sleeps with Sarah.
And then Abraham does will.
It's like a you know ancient nor Eastern version of Jerry
Springer. Like who's the baby daddy? We don't know.
Okay, it's a threat to the line of the seed.
But instead God preserves the line. He pulls Sarah
out of there. How does he do that through sending plagues on Egypt. Does
that sound familiar to you?
Abraham comes back out of Egypt back into the land.
God makes a promise again in Genesis 15. What is Abraham do
immediately?
He sleeps with his.
Wife's servant Hagar who happens to be by the way. What an
Egyptian slave woman. Does that something here Egyptian slavery?
right
obedience
no faithlessness
God makes another promise great faithlessness
Finally Abraham seems to get it on Mount Moriah where God
calls him to sacrifice Isaac.
By the end of the story Abraham does really believe he buries
Sarah he purchases the first piece of land at
Syria Sarah's burial place the cave of mock pull
up.
Abraham the rest of Genesis is
a search for the seed through Genesis through Abraham's line. Abraham
has a son by Sarah.
He has another son Ishmael, but he has a son by Sarah Isaac.
Isaac marries a woman named Rebecca who
initially is barren.
I mean there's a there's a pattern for you as well. Sarah old
and barren.
Rebecca barren woman God opens her womb
she has twins.
Jacob and Esau Jacob and Esau is a great story. We don't
have time to go into it. But if we did we would see
that Jacob in his treachery.
Is really just exhibiting faithlessness and God
to fulfill his promises and so his rate. So is Rebecca for
that matter?
God tells Rebecca Jacob's going to be the son of the promise but Rebecca
doesn't trust God to make that happen. So Rebecca and
Jacob take into their own hands.
With bad consequences. So again faithlessness faithfulness of
God.
Jacob eventually marries Four Women if you
read the story, it's obvious. That's not a recommended life
strategy and they eventually
he has 12 sons by those four
women.
One of those Sons is the first son that he has by
Rachel the woman that he really loves.
and Joseph again looks like
a new Adam if you know the story of Joseph, you
know that Joseph is
clothed by his dad.
Gets that Dreamcoat Technicolor those
words are not in the Bible, but he gets a coat from
his dad and his brother and he
tells his brothers. Hey guys, I'm gonna be in charge of you one day which is also is again
not a great leadership strategy and they sell
them into slavery to Egypt.
There's that theme again slavery in Egypt.
And Joseph goes into slavery. He's
he
of everybody else in Genesis. What is Joseph in the face of
Temptation?
When Potiphar's wife tries to get
Joseph, what does Joseph do?
He flees from sin.
unlike Adam
unlike Cain unlike lamech
unlike Noah unlike Abraham unlike Isaac
unlike his dad Jacob Joseph flees
from sin.
Wait a minute.
Now we're talking.
He gets put in jail, though.
whoops
go to jail. Well, wait a minute. Joseph can interpret dreams
and you might think well, that's cool. But what does
that do anything? Well, here's the deal in the dreams that Joseph interprets, especially
for Pharaoh. What can Joseph tell the difference between with
pharaoh?
There is seven years of what?
Plenty and seven years of famine and in
Hebrew.
Especially when he's talking about the grain.
It's seven years of good grain.
And seven years of evil or bad
grain.
What can Joseph tell the difference between?
Good.
and Evil
the Baker and the cup Bearer he can tell the difference between life
and death.
Joseph flees from sin Joseph can tell the difference
between good and evil Joseph Rises to
second in command in Egypt just under
the authority of the king. Guess what he represents.
He represents the authority of the king in the land that the king
gives him.
Joseph receives the ring and the cloak that
Pharaoh gives him he's clothed in the king's image.
Joseph gets a wife.
from pharaoh
The king gives him a helpmate.
Wait a minute.
What does all that sound like?
Sounds like Adam again, right?
Joseph sounds like a new Adam.
Joseph is second in command. He's clothed in the image of the king. He's
given a wife by the king. He's given dominion over
a land. That is fruitful.
His name Joseph's name means to add
or to multiply in Hebrew.
Not exactly the same word, but it's a synonym.
Joseph looks like a new Adam. What's the problem?
Well, if this is the seed first of
all, what's the seed supposed to do in order to banish the
effects of sin and restore what Adam lost?
What did God say that the seed of woman would do to the
serpent?
crush his head
Joseph doesn't Crush anybody's head and in his
story as far as I can tell.
What's another problem? Where is he?
He's in Egypt. Is he in the land that God promised
to Abraham?
Nope.
There's a final problem.
And I want you to look at Genesis 37.
And this is this is one of those places where I want you to see that paying attention
to patterns and weird stuff can help you read your
Bible.
Sorry Genesis 38. So Genesis 37 is the
story of Joseph and his 12 Brothers.
Where they sell them into slavery Genesis 39 picks
up on Joseph's story. But then
in the middle, there's this very strange story.
That if you made it through the genealogies of Genesis 5 and
you made it through the genealogies of dentists 10 and
you made it through all the story of Abraham and Isaac
and Jacob and even to Joseph and you get to
Genesis 38 you might be going at this point. Okay God
I can't take this anymore. It's too weird.
Listen to the story.
And feels like are you really gonna read this? I'm Really Gonna read it. It happened
at that time that Judah went down from his brothers and turned aside to
a certain adulamite whose name was Hira.
They're Judah saw the daughter of a certain Canaanite whose name
Yeshua. He took her and went into her and she canceived and borisan and he
called his name her.
She conceived again and borisan and she called his name Onan yet
again. She bore a son and she called his name Sheila Judah
was in chezib when she
bore him.
And Judah took a wife or his first born her name
was Tamar, but Ur, Jesus firstborn was wicked in
the sight of the Lord and Lord put him to death.
Then Judah said to own and go into your brother's wife and perform
the duty of a brother-in-law to her and raise up Offspring for your brother.
But Onan neither The Offspring would not be his so whenever
he went into his brother's wife. He would waste the seamen on the ground. So as not
to give The Offspring to his brother.
And what he did was wicked in the side of the Lord and he put him to death also.
Then Judas had to Tamar his daughter-in-law remain a
widow and your father's house till Shayla my son grows up.
For he feared that he would die like his brothers. So Tamar went
and remained in her father's house.
In the course of time the wife of Judah. She was
daughter died when Judah was comforted. He went up to timna
to a sheep shearers. He and his friend hero the adulomite.
And when Tamar was told your father-in-law is going up to timna.
This year's sheep. She took off her widow's garments and covered herself with a
veil wrapping herself up inside of the instruments to Naim which
is on the road to timna for she saw that Shayla
was grown up and she had not been given to him in marriage.
When Judah saw her he thought she was a prostitute for she had covered her
face. He turned to her at the roadside and said come let
me come into you for he did not know that she was his daughter-in-law.
She said what will you give me that? You may come into me? He answered.
I will send you a young goat from the flock and she said if you
give me a pledge until you send it he said what Pledge Your
Signet ring your cord and your staff.
So get into your went into her and she can see now Judah finds
out. She's pregnant and gets mad.
Says, all right, let's you know put her to death.
And Tamar says fine.
But before you kill me, you should know the man
who got me pregnant owns this ring this
chord and this staff and then she pulls all that
stuff out and judah's like oh, that was me. Never mind and
Tamar Bears, two sons
at the end of this chapter
Perez
and Zara
now Zara
Zara means seed
that's the word for seed.
And he's got a Scarlet thread tied around his arm.
But he's not the seed.
Perez the line through him the Messiah
comes the point though is this
Joseph looks like the seed.
He's wise.
He obeys he rules. He's fruitful.
He's clothed in the image of the king receives
a wife from the King.
But he's not the seed. He's not in Israel. He doesn't
destroy the serpent and he's not the son
of Judah or he's not the son of Jacob through
whom the line of the seed passes. That's Judah and that's
why judah's story is sitting here in the middle of Joseph's.
To remind us that God is faithful to
his promises in the midst of our unfaithfulness. Judah is
probably one of the worst people in the
Book of Genesis, which is really saying something.
And yet here God is remaining faithful
to his promises.
Joseph is a picture of the new Adam but he's not
the new Adam. We're still waiting on this son of
Zara.
now
when we get to the end of Genesis, everybody dies spoiler
alert.
But Judah Jacob
sorry blesses his sons and into Judah.
He says in verse 9 of chapter. 49 Judah
is Alliance Cub from the
prey or sorry verse eight Judah your brother shall praise
you your hand shall be on the neck of your enemies. Your Father's son. Shall
bow down before you Judah is Alliance come from
the prey my son you have gone up. He's stoop down. He crouches a
line as a lioness Who Dares Rouse him the scepter shall
not depart from Judah nor the ruler staff
from between his feet until tribute comes to him and to
him shall be The Obedience of his
peoples of the peoples binding
is full of the vine is donkey's Colt to the
choice fine. He has washed his garments and wine and his vest here
in the blood of grapes. His eyes are darker than Wine and his teeth.
Wider than milk. That's Song of Solomon by
the way, so Judah here.
Is identified as the line of the seed this this language about
the scepter and ruling Etc. He's going to have dominion over
the Earth.
What God has done through the Book of Genesis is what
he says.
What Joseph says to his brothers?
in chapter 50
verse 20
as for you
Adam
Kane lamech NOAA Abraham
Isaac Jacob
Judah
us
as for you
as for me
we all mean evil against God.
apart from the grace of Christ
But God meant it uses it for good.
To bring it about that many people should be kept alive as they are today.
in the midst of
Adam
Abraham judah's faithlessness
God is faithful because
He's bringing about the salvation of many.
Through his faithfulness.
That's the message of Genesis really the message the Old Testament.
We're still searching for the seed at the end. We haven't found him yet.
Okay, so that search isn't over.
But what we've seen in Genesis is a pattern for the rest of
the Old Testament.
In Genesis 1 and 2 we saw the pattern.
Of God's kingdom. This is from a guy named Vaughn Roberts
who wrote a good book called God's big picture if you want to check that out.
He says that Genesis 1 and 2 is the pattern of
God's Kingdom.
In Genesis 3 we see that God's kingdom is
broken by sin.
But Genesis 4 through 50 is
the promise of God's faithfulness to bring about the kingdom
in spite of our unfaithfulness. We're still waiting at the
end.
Okay, so I'm going to take the last few minutes that I have and
just mention.
Also the next book Exodus and what
I want to do is talk about the Exodus event because these
two things go together what God promises to Abraham
and then how God is going to accomplish it in The
Exodus.
These two things go together and the next week.
Maybe we'll make it.
Some at some point in the New Testament.
I don't know but what I want you to hear
as we wrap up for a few
minutes is what God is going
to do.
Is found in the promises day Abraham.
How he is going to do that.
Is pictured in The Exodus?
Okay, so what God is going to do he's going to
he's going to restore what Adam lost.
He's going to redeem his people so their fruitful so
they can rule obey care for his place.
He's gonna do that through the seed of woman. How is he going to do that? We haven't
really seen that yet.
How is God going to do this we've gotten hints.
We got a hint in Genesis 3.
with the sacrificial
skins that Adam and Eve or we got a hint in Genesis
6 when God calls Noah
to build an ark and he puts a Remnant on the ark to save them. He he
judges the world but he saves a
Remnant but how is he going to do that?
Exodus is the answer that question 400 years
after Joseph dies Pharaoh doesn't remember
Joseph.
And enslaves the Egyptians now there's a lot of detail here
that I really wish that we could go through for instance. Moses's
little basket that he's put
in to save him from the pharaoh's decree
that all the male children will be killed.
Which by the way has the gospel of Matthew start?
Here it says kill all the male. Children Moses is a little
basket. It says it's made of a product called
bitumen and pitch.
And that's the same thing that Noah uses to build the ark.
so here's Moses comparing himself to Noah, which is
a little bit pretentious but whatever so
God calls Moses to be his
spokesman his Prophet to this
evil King.
If you were to study Egyptian religion
and the place of the Pharaoh and
and all their gods you would you would
know that the Pharaoh was kind of a representation of
the Divine to the Egyptians.
And so what's happening is that Moses the representative of
Yahweh. The one true God.
Is going to Pharaoh the representation of these idolatrous
false gods.
And it's a Clash.
It's a clash between the one true God.
and our false gods
It's a clash really.
between
the god of the Bible the only true God
and idolatry
everything else
And how does God rescue his people from the bondage
they are in?
to this representation of idolatry
How does God rescue his people?
He sends.
plagues
and if you study The Exodus event, you'll know
that each of those 10 plagues is an attack on one
of the Egyptian gods.
To say Yahweh is more powerful than you.
And we get through eight of them.
And then there's the ninth plague which is Darkness.
And then the tenth plague is what?
What's the 10th plague in Texas?
death of the firstborn son
Here's how God is going to rescue his people.
through miraculous signs that ends in darkness and
the death of the firstborn son and only those who are
what
covered by the blood of the Lamb
will be spared.
How is God going to save his people?
How is God going to restore? What Adam lost? How is
he going to reverse the curse of Adam? How is he going to redeem the
world from this bondage to sin?
Through victory over his enemies that happens in the
death of the firstborn son and the blood of the Lamb.
That's how God is going to do it.
And after he rescues them, where does he take him? He takes
them through the waters of the Red Sea.
Towards supposed to be into the Promised Land.
Listen, that's a picture of salvation.
How is God going to rescue his people through the death
of the firstborn son and the blood of the Lamb?
What happens when Jesus dies Darkness?
death
blood
Redemption
How do we enter into his place his kingdom
through the waters of baptism? This is always been
how God is going to rescue his people.
This is always been the plan for what God is going to
do. No. Nobody should have been surprised when
Jesus shows up and says, hey everybody.
I'm gonna die.
That's been the plan all along.
God pictures it for us in The Exodus. That's
how God is going to save his people he's going to
Gain, victory over his enemies through death of the firstborn son the
blood of the lamb and he's gonna bring them out of bondage and into
his place to live with them forever.
So I have made a lot of promises
about where we'll get in the coming weeks.
And even tonight I made a lot of promises so I'm not going to make any more
promises. I'll be here next week. I think unless the
weather is bad.
Let's all pray that it's not and we'll get somewhere in the Bible.
How about that? Is that fair? All right. Thank you all very much. Let me pray
for us and we'll be done God. Thank you so much for your word. We
thank you that you have given it to us as bread.
to eat
as Manna From Heaven Lord that you sustain us.
You nourish Us by the power of your word
that is.
inspired by your Holy Spirit and that testifies
from page to page from Genesis 1 to revelation
22 to your son Jesus.
Or we thank you for sending your son. We thank
you that you have redeemed Us by the blood of the Lamb the
death of your firstborn, son.
And we pray Lord that we would walk in newness of
life.
That you've given to us through him and by your
spirit.
And we ask an in Christ's name.
amen, I'm
let me know if you have questions.